welcome to another dr sandler's honest
reviews where i give
unvarnished analysis and discussion
to you about usually recent works
in practical philosophy defined very
broadly
so that it would extend out to
organizational things and leadership
or to self-help and everything in
between
the book that i have for you this time
is pretty recent
2020 uh it's by barbara h
rosenwein and it's called anger the
conflicted history of an emotion you
notice the four
angers there which is quite a nice
touch for the the covers by is from yale
university press
and it's come out fairly recently um
not counting the bibliography there's
about
200 200 pages of
actual text to this so
it's kind of a short book and that's
actually going to be one of its
shortcomings as we'll talk about soon
to give you a preview of what's ahead i
found this very
interesting but also somewhat
frustrating book
i qualifiedly
recommend its purchase or its reading
if it's the sort of thing that you want
after you hear
about what i have to say about the book
so
let's launch right into the discussion
of the text
i like to begin by discussing three big
s's
the style of the work giving some sort
of
overview of its structure and providing
you with
a kind of summary and the summary
and the structure are actually pretty
closely tied together because if you
look at the table of contents and the
way
that the book is arranged it it's broken
down into
three main sections three main
we could call them baskets into which a
whole bunch of stuff is being thrown
so part one is titled anger rejected
in parentheses almost absolutely and
there's some discussion in there about
important movements in thought
and life you know buddhism stoicism for
example
some discussion about christianity and
some other things as well
part two is called anger as a vice but
also in parentheses
sometimes as a virtue that's only got
three chapters
to it one of which is devoted to
aristotle and his heirs we'll come back
to that in a moment
and then there is this part three
discussing
natural anger which actually has
uh yeah four chapters to it and then a
very short conclusion
my anger our anger and you can say that
the book's
orientation is from
thinking about anger in you know
really early human history
um not so early on
but let's call it from the time of the
development
of wisdom traditions philosophies of
ways of life
and philosophical enterprises all the
way up to
the present she discusses the current
political situation
as she's writing it in in the united
states
with um you know the trump
administration and him having
gotten in we could arguably say uh
riding a crust of anger in in many
respects
um anger is certainly a central issue
in the politics and culture of our time
and then there's you know
it's punctuated by a whole bunch of
discussions on the way and you could say
you know is this
really a history of an emotion
um yes and no and we'll get to more of
that
uh down the line but it is presented
as if it is kind of a a history and
there's also some
examination of anthropological studies
some incorporation
of psychological schools approaches
whatever we want to call them so
there's a lot of stuff actually being
put in here
and bundled together
as far as the the style goes i'd say you
know it's a pretty
readable book i don't think this is
going to be
particularly challenging there are a few
places where
a casual reader could get tripped up and
i'll talk about those
later but you know for the most part
it's it's quite
quite decent quite good in in many
respects
as these books often work
there's quite a few little narratives
and you know what about you know if you
were in this sort of situation things
within it i'll also mention that
interestingly there's like a whole
section
of illustrations and plates
stuck in the middle of the book many of
which are
worth checking out right many of which
you would also be able to find
quite easily online but they're you know
they're nice to
to look at and here's finally in the
very end right our contemporary
politics and it i would say it's not
quite a history as such it's more
a set of stories that are
bundled together under common themes
and arranged as as if it is a history so
it's a story
of stories um you know there's
some structured thematic historical
discussions of various
aspects of anger none of them really are
that long or that sustained but you know
what do you we've got a 200 page book
here to to work with
so it is interesting to note that
the introduction is a good bit longer
than the conclusion
part one is a good bit longer than
in its chapter structure than the other
chapters
although part three is actually quite
quite long as well
so yeah that's probably enough about
structure style summary to give you an
idea of what you're getting
into if you if you want to crack this
book open
what are some of the key ideas or
main features or points of the work so
in the introduction
she takes an interesting turn she talks
about homer's iliad
beginning with an order to the muse
anger oh goddess
sing the anger of achilles right and she
says in a way
anger is the first word in the written
literature of the west which is kind of
a conventional way to begin
talking about the history of theories
or literature on anger she's not the
first person to
make that point and then she says i'd
prefer not to start with the iliad
although she actually has started with
the iliad
i'd rather begin with my own story
and then look back and she tells this
story about being three years old
having a beloved rubber baby doll which
could do all sorts of things
she says i love that doll fiercely but
i'd also hide behind the living room
sofa and beat it soundly
pummeling it with my fist i clearly
remember the turning point i heard my
mother say to a visitor
that girl has got a lot of anger in her
i knew she was
talking about me i stopped i was ashamed
what was this anger that i had
a lot of and she's going to come back to
that doll
and this uh sort of incident over and
over again
through the text and she's gonna bring
in other people's incidents
as well or narratives or stories
which is you know kind of a conventional
way of of doing these
these sorts of things it provides a way
for
the author to reach out to the reader
and get them to perhaps identify
or at least empathize or be emotionally
connected
and and that's an important feature
much later in the work page here we go
it's uh in the discussion society's
child she talks about
her work as a historian and she says as
a historian
i prefer to think in terms of
emotional communities that means looking
in depth at the micro context in which
people like anthony is somebody
struggling with anger
and all of us live and feel done
thoroughly and properly this means
exploring biographies
whole dossiers of writings oral
histories and interviews creative works
not just of one person but of his or her
friends family's co-workers and so on
it means deeply embedding people in the
nitty-gritty of their lives to the
fullest extent
possible only then can we begin to know
what their and
their society's many and sometimes
contradictory emotional norms and values
are
different emotional communities may
practice superficially similar
sorts of anger even so the feeling
itself will have many different values
and meanings and will be experienced
differently and then she gives some
examples of knights
and monks and troubadour poets singers
right
and anger is different for each of them
in this case and
these are kind of good examples right
because it shows where we're not just
talking about like our own contemporary
emotional communities we can look at at
past ones and we can
penetrate into them and i think that's
that's quite true
i think there is on the on the one hand
a lot of discussion of
theories of anger very short and
sometimes
a little bit too superficial treatments
of them coming from you know
seneca or aristotle or others
and then you know those play a role
oftentimes in these emotional
communities
and the bridge between them often isn't
all that well
sketched out but what we could imagine
is some of these you know for example
the monks are going to be well informed
by these things that they're copying out
and talking about within the monasteries
perhaps even the troubadours are or the
knights possibly could be
as well right so
you know this is this is actually you
know kind of a good
point to make especially since she she
brings this up precisely
because there's these analyses
especially by psychologists
that are very general she says the
problem with analyses like these is that
they're exceedingly general as if
everyone subject to the same cultural
inputs will come away with the same
emotions this is not really the case
we must go beyond grand abstractions in
order to understand each individual
situation
more fully and specifically so
you know that that's a really good point
i would say that this
work as a whole raises some some very
central issues that are concerned with
or
raised by this emotion of anger which
if you're lucky enough not to experience
it you're certainly experiencing
others having it so it's kind of an ever
present human
response a set of responses really that
we have to deal with
she also brings up you know these these
seemingly problematic counter-example
cultures like the um
the same the utmo the foray
and she does so fairly early on in the
work
some people are probably already
conversant with it these are these are
peoples where
anger in their culture is viewed as
something very negative
immature something that one needs to try
to eliminate
to repress to get rid of to replace with
other things right so there's some good
discussion in there
like for example she says it would seem
the semi link anger violence and peace
by showing no anger
they signal their non-violence and
peacefulness
but you know as she points out they have
a word for anger
and they sometimes engage in violence
that's not motivated by anger as well so
getting rid of anger
doesn't automatically get rid of
violence they may be a more peaceful
society
than us but you know they're not um
they're not like totally peaceful she
talks about the
utku who censure anger
quite a bit um here we go the
uh this is from the book never in anger
um gene briggs chronicle the people that
like the semaine never
seldom get angry get angry though it
could consider
anger a childish emotion one that's
normally outgrown living in fear of it
and avoiding situations
that might give it rise they consider an
anger a kind of unhappiness
one of their words for it means
unsmiling
children are taught to deny that they
feel
uh urulu this this unsmilingness
and people call each other uh
to express their disapproval of their
nasty temper right
and so you know does that mean that
nobody gets angry
no not not at all she says
anthropologists constantly cite the semi
and utku
as examples of anger-free communities
these are not the only groups that
practice non-anger
similar practices have been chronicled
for the foray of new guinea
right and and you know they they say
things like we don't get angry
and she says why not well because they
have social practices that mitigates
anger sway
giving when asked not asking for much
laughing not hitting
right but this is this is also a way of
dealing with anger that has its own
perils
and problematics that arise and i think
that's that's actually you know
something
good to point out with this work because
there's often too
superficial or reliance on these
ethnographies
that are unduly optimistic about the
people they're studying
and about their prospects for us living
a similar
kind of life another thing that she does
consider that's quite important
throughout the work is the possibility
of
virtuous anger is this i mean aristotle
talks about this in the angry words
uh chapter she talks about the
people hauled into court for uttering
insults they sometimes defended
themselves by claiming
they had been drunk or spoken out of
anger at augsburg penalties were waived
when insults were hurled out of
excessive drunkenness sudden anger
in these cases anger was assessed as
uncontrollable madness
other municipal leaders disagreed in
their view anger was no defense at all
but in some instances anger was
considered
proper when for example it defended the
honor of an individual
or his or her family some civic codes
even included the right of retort
so there's there's a lot of different
possible attitudes
and attentivenesses towards
expressions outbursts of anger and
acting
on anger including the possibility of
something that we could call virtuous or
righteous anger and that's going to
change from
situation to situation culture to
culture
as well i should actually talk a little
bit before we
go into the next section who is she
engaging
with so i mean the very first chapter
is actually about buddhism and so
you know that's quite important buddhism
is still a major world religion
it has you might say it punches above
it's its demographic weight in part
because
of the incorporation of so much buddhist
stuff
into say mind contemporary mindfulness
practices
and some new agey stuff as well
she also talks about stoicism and
neo-stoicism
and that's that's important because
that's also a large worldwide movement
there's been a stoic
renaissance as of lately aristotelianism
is important there's a little bit of
discussion of the platonists
um you know there's there's a lot of
discussion of of christian authors
uh and adaptations of the the you know
pre-christian
heritage in there um there's there's
a good bit of discussion of the
medievals and early
moderns as i mentioned there's also you
know talk about
other peoples about various schools of
psychology
there's good discussion in an entire
chapter about the early
medical traditions including galen and
and all the way up to you know sort of
uh
contemporary psychology right the in the
lab chapter
that follows it and then there's you
know there's a good
bit of discussion about current thought
on
anger justice protest
civil rights social justice you know
how how appropriate is it to involve
anger in that so those are a lot of
things that are being touched on
let's talk now about good points of the
work
so when this book is good it is
quite good uh rosenwine has a real
talent as you can guess
as a historian for storytelling
as well as you know doing the the
research that you find
in the bibliography you know and in the
extensive notes so there's a lot of
you know parts here and there in the
work where you're like oh that's that's
really well
put or that's a good explanation of that
or that's that
example is really dead on um
i think that's that's quite interesting
one prime example of this if you're not
familiar
with him would be she brings this up uh
several different times
a medieval thinker william peraltas
whose analysis of sins of the tongue
became very
important for thinking about all the
different ways in which people are
misusing
speech and could be doing something they
need to confess
or to atone for so you know when she's
doing that kind of work i think this is
actually quite a
good book i think the discussions
of contemporary psychology
are you know they're short succinct and
pretty good i would say pretty dead on
about
uh understanding how these these things
work and she finds antecedents to them
saying darwin or
william james which is which is kind of
nice in terms of history of ideas
um she also has a really great
discussion about how
how tropes within society are often
used to control people and one example
that she brings up
is the trope of the angry black woman
image so she says while some black women
find the epithet funny or even
empowering
others consider it hateful therapist
wendy ashley argues that the angry black
woman image contributes
to misdiagnoses and faulty treatments of
black women in clinical settings
affecting their self-esteem the label is
sometimes so overwhelming that the women
may suppress disclosures
of anger and minimize its impact in
their lives
they may actually become angry though
for jones that anger is is a good sort
one stirred by social injustice not the
overbearing and loudmouth brand of anger
portrayed by the
stereotype and you know then she goes on
to talk about legal scholars
who have other concerns and and i think
that what we can find
in culture after culture after culture
is that there are
stereotypes of anger i mean we could
think about what happens
in antiquity leading
into the christian era and the portrayal
of women's anger as particularly
dangerous deadly um you know john
chrysostom for example talks about
you know women's anger as as sort of you
know much more common than men's
anger um and you know i think that
there's a there's a lot there to
unpack and so talking about that
particular
instance i think is quite helpful we
could broaden it to talk about
people who are often not allowed to
express
anger or placed in a kind of double bind
where
you know they're supposed to be angry
enough to protest the injustice against
themselves
and when they do protest and display
anger they're viewed as being out of
control
then we get to police them and crack
heads and all of that sort of stuff so
you know there's there's a there's
that's a really good point i think that
one of the really strong points of the
work
is also going back to that
anthropological stuff
to to kind of call bs on these
ethnographies
and all this other journalistic writing
that says you know
this group of people they they recognize
how dangerous
anger is and their whole society trains
them to not do that maybe we could do
that and uh
rosenstein is you know she's looking at
that with kind of a
skeptical eye that i think is is
actually quite refreshing
so i'm happy with that as well um the
discussion
of contemporary psychology
includes um you know some some basic
uh thumbnail sketches of a couple
different points of view um
what are what are often called the basic
emotion school
the psychological constructionists
and then an activist she doesn't endorse
any one single point of view
uh you know among these different
theories which are sort of like learning
theories or business theories
all of them when you read them and you
hear about them you're like
yeah there's a lot that's being left out
there especially if you know much about
the history of of
anger in the theories that she's
discussing
in the book as well and i'll say this
you know she gives
she gives some discussions of classical
philosophical slash religious
psychological
slash medical perspectives on anger
that again when they're good they're
quite good and so i think that is
a nice selling point of the work
as as well so there's there's actually
quite a few good points about the work
that you might want to attune to
i do unfortunately have quite a few
things
to complain about when it comes to the
work i mentioned that i found it
rather frustrating i think that
one of the like central overarching
problems with the book as a whole
is that it's it's sort of promising to
do a lot
and can't bring that off within 200
pages
in order to do an adequate job
with a lot of the theories and
perspectives that are being discussed
there would you know you just require a
lot more in-depth discussion of them
and at times it kind of reads like
somebody who hasn't engaged enough
with at least i'm talking here primarily
with theorists of
anger uh not necessarily all the other
stuff that she's talking about with like
emotional communities
but it reads like somebody who
read a lot of summaries but didn't spend
a lot of time
with the original texts and thinkers
to to really you know
grapple with and grasp their fundamental
perspectives
um so there there are some some really
big oversights i would say in the work
you know
there's a significant discussion of
stoicism
and then neo-stoicism and barely any
mention
of epictetus so you know seneca does
have a book
on anger right and that's important but
that wasn't he wasn't the only author
talking about that
um nor was cicero who sides with with uh
the stoics on
on anger epictetus has a lot to say
about it so does marcus aurelius
and i'm not sure why they're not there
especially since neo-stoicism
wasn't just reading seneca and
responding to seneca epictetus
became front and center in their in the
renaissance in early modern
age so yeah you know the stoic thing
that's a
problem um the discussion of aristotle
rightly picks up
on the rhetoric it discusses
it references the uh rhetori
aristotle's definition of anger doesn't
actually quote it from the rhetoric
which is kind of a weird thing just
mention certain aspects of it aristotle
has
you know probably in ancient times the
most
well thought out complex definition of
anger which you'll find in rhetoric book
two
um aristotle also discusses anger
throughout his works both of the nic the
nico mccain and eudaimian ethics
it's actually one of the reasons for
social breakdown in the politics
and it's weird to see no discussion of
that here at all
it would make sense if the main text
that she's read is the rhetoric and the
nick of mccain ethics and then nothing
beyond that
so you know i find that a bit
problematic
as a researcher on the philosophical
side
the discussion of natural anger it would
have been very natural to bring in the
epicureans
who actually talk about natural anger
zero discussion of that in here as well
so that that's kind of a problem
um the chapter on buddhism you know
it's it's good it's it's not good in
certain parts and part of it
is i would say a bit of clumsiness
in explaining to the the casual reader
who these different groups of buddhists
were so
you know she talks about um the mahayana
scriptures
and um you know
that's a main vehicle a main movement
in in buddhism and then she talks about
the vajrayana scriptures
uh you know starts talking a bit about
tibet and then starts talking about
tantric buddhism
and you would never get any idea in
reading this that you know
tantric buddhism and vajrayana buddhism
are connected with each other you'd
think that they're actually like two
different things by the way that she's
framing it and so there's there's some
malapropisms i would say
in how some things are presented
they're things that where if you if you
already know the the scene
it's it's more like well that's kind of
a weird choice but if you don't you'd
actually be misled
at another point she actually tells us
that seneca
has three books on anger when really
what we mean is that his one his one
book
on anger is divided into three
chapters that in ancient philosophy
ancient literature we call books because
they're originally scrolls right
and so that you know might lead the
casual reader into thinking that seneca
actually has
more books on anger than the one that
she's
mentioning so again something that you
know
it should have been caught somebody
definitely you know
with yale university press somebody
should have somebody should have caught
on to that
um what else there's um
[Music]
in the stoicism part there's a lot of
discussion of
ancient stoicism primarily jacinica as i
mentioned
uh neo-stoicism which is quite
interesting right that's worth checking
out
um zero discussion of modern stoicism
so it's as if she's unaware that
when it comes to philosophies as ways of
life that are
you know resuscitating ancient
philosophy that's the biggest game in
town followed by the epicureans
right who also gets zero real discussion
aristotelians get some discussion but
but not too
too much the discussions of
anger and social justice are interesting
but they're rather thin i think they
could have been
fleshed out a lot more you know she
brings up as everybody does martin
luther king
doesn't discuss any of the things that
martin luther king himself says about
anger
which was quite important you know
brings up of course audrey lord's
the uses of anger which is quite
important and good
i would say doesn't go far enough in
discussion of that
uh what else um there's there's places
where she kind of gets
aristotle actually wrong
here's one prime example she talks about
you know plato the solar mind had three
parts reason spirit
appetite she
doesn't talk at all about the fact that
spirit is the part of us that gets angry
right uh so that that's a that's kind of
a significant issue there
but then she she also says aristotle had
a different focus
he was interested in the things of the
world both natural and man-made and the
logical tools necessary to understand
them as if plato wasn't
you know plants have a nutritive soul
animals have a bipartite soul
nutritive and sensitive humans have a
tripartite soul nutritive sensitive and
intellective
yeah kind of and kind of not i mean this
is one of those things where you like
again this looks like it came from a
summary rather than a
reading across aristotle's corpus the
intellective
has two parts in turn one logical and
the other a logical
that's a weird way to translate rational
and irrational and the
irrational is the orecticae part the
desirous part the part that feels
affections and can also
you know listen to reason and then she
doesn't actually talk about the
uh rational part um
having parts itself which here's a
little super clear about
in the nick of mccain ethics right so
you get the sense that she
doesn't fully understand some of
the thinkers that she's she's working
with which i think is a problem there's
also
you know a discussion of thomas aquinas
um
nested in there as well aquinas being
sort of like the
preeminent um
medieval thinker which he really wasn't
asking franciscan if that was the case
uh and they will they will say no they
certainly did not
uh have a lot of love for her for thomas
i mean she does say some things here
that are that are quite good you know
she talks about the difference between
desiring emotions
and the erasable emotions right
and she says what what is anger's role
it's one of the eraskable emotions whose
job is to help the desiring emotions to
get to their goal
the path the love's object is often
beset by difficulties
and so she's kind of circling around
something that is absolutely
central thomas says
the irascapable emotions not just anger
but the ones of the erasable appetite
are there to help us attain
the difficult good which then he goes on
to explain in
in great detail this it gets one line
here this is a major insight by aquinas
that i i don't see her really engaging
with
you know that's kind of a a problem i
would say
i mean later she says the aristotelian
and thomistic views of emotions had
enormous impact on subsequent theories
and practices
in one way or another every thinker
dealing with the emotions has had to
respond to them
i don't know that that's really the case
i would say there's there's more moving
parts going on particularly in the
renaissance and early modern period when
epicureanism stoicism come on the scene
all sorts of other things are being
brought into bear as well including you
know
augustine as well so i i think that
that's
you know another example uh where if you
know what she's referencing you're
you're going to be unsatisfied with it
and so you know for the casual reader
are those
significant obstacles i don't know i
mean
i think it's a it's a good enough book
that you could read your way through it
if you know that this is not
the be all end-all definitive take
but just a set of interesting things
being thrust out there
and that you should do more research
yourself
along the lines of the thinkers and
movements and
ideas that's that she's suggesting i
think this could actually be a great
springboard
i could see using this in a class where
you're like okay so
you know here's the picture of aristotle
we're getting from here
um what else do we need to add to the
picture but you know i don't know that a
lot of people will necessarily
get that so i'm a bit worried by it you
know it does not live up to the blurbs
in the back
you know a fascinating ambitious survey
of a range of takes on anger for many
traditions and time periods uh yeah okay
it is if it's ambitious it's not
fulfilling
the ambition and it is fascinating in
parts and frustrating in other parts so
that's probably enough to say about
about the downsides
so my my final thoughts this is going to
be a little bit idiosyncratic but you
know i am a researcher who's focused for
the last 20 years
on anger found in quite a few of the
traditions that she is discussing
in this book so i'm going to bring in
aristotle again from the the rhetoric
he talks about an emotion which in greek
is
zelos and we translate it you could
translate it as
zeal but it would be a bit misleading
it's translated typically
in aristotle stuff as emulation
and it's a pain that you feel when you
see
somebody else doing something that
you think is something you have the
potential for
but you're not able to do it at this
point in time and so
you you know you see like a star athlete
who's doing amazing stuff you're like oh
man i i used to be good at that i wish i
would have like
done better or a musician you know i i
watch basis and i'm like oh if i would
have stuck with my
bass i'd never be steve harris good but
i could at least be nikki six good
right and i sometimes feel that when i
read books i'm like oh
man that's a book i would have liked to
have written
but i'm not really up to that sort of
thing so it's a good thing that they
wrote it
i don't have that feeling about this
book
and i'm not like uh there's there's
probably many many of us who could
who could say similar things about this
um it's
it's it's a decent book it's good in
parts
it's the more you know it it becomes
more and more frustrating
in the parts where you're like well this
is not a great
treatment here and some of this is
actually misleading or left some things
out
so you know it really is up to you what
you want to make of it and whether you
think this is
is worth acquiring
for your own stuff it could be a good
what we call beach reading where you're
doing something
and you want to you know have something
that's got some meat
to it some some intellectual uh
nourishment
but you don't want it too difficult too
challenging
and you like your stuff in you know
bite-sized pieces then this would
probably be
a good book it is very good in
its narrative storytelling i would say
that that's quite good
so i'm giving this kind of a mixed
review
you